previously on lost oh I can't last
episode this close this close to
throwing up but here we are again ten
more things that you shouldn't go below
I will google it for you browse and you
can watch me suffer
all right so according to this list
we're on lap rayel let me know how far
you make it in this video
he's another thought by I mean they're
pretty [ __ ] terrifying and I would
never even go [ __ ] anywhere near 100
I think that do you remember that
starburst monster that was in the sand
pit I think that was inspired by this
why do they ask oh god they have faces
oh oh they photoshop it oh why would you
do that the [ __ ] is wrong with you
perhaps this city was it oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah oh it's sad how it looks like
all right let's just move on two kids
one sandbox original video what is that
this is not sooner for guys or girls is
it over
I want to cry
what the [ __ ] is wrong with people I've
joked upon shoving stuff down the dick
call but I didn't know it was actually
physically possible all right this one
meatspin yeah yeah I've seen meatspin a
lot of times this is like my home
[Music]
or anyone who's seen this video if that
song ever shows up at a party just look
around just look around you and you will
see like all the people getting
triggered you'll know you'll know right
away by looking up and everyone else's
faces who's seeing that video and who
hasn't all right let's move for girls
finger pain that can't be that bad
[Music]
when it's going on no no no no more [ __ ]
I can't eat the [ __ ] man
[Music]
No
all right
it's done this is not how you finger
pain this is not how you think of me
oh yeah a tough girl
top girl is my vein I can appreciate
time girl i love fishes calm like the
music
[Music]
oh it goes in the butthole I fish the
fish goes in the bubble is you're gonna
put them out just gonna provide a shitty
[ __ ] are there oh good it's coming
[Music]
still better than the Star Wars prequels
oh god oh god no I've heard about this
one I've heard about this one since I
was a kid but I've never actually seen
it
it's called pain Olympics
[Music]
what are you doing
are you doing
why are you doing this
[Music]
what you think I can't tie a [ __ ]
rope around my bed what is this
No
[Applause]
[Music]
that's it that's it I'm not doing this
anymore I'm not [ __ ] doing this this
is a stupid idea
mr. Thomas [ __ ] [ __ ] I ever [ __ ]
seen him on life [ __ ] this
alright that was it for this video Wow
we did it we [ __ ] did it I know that
was eight but I can't I if we went
through all 20 that's it for now
Julie will like if you enjoyed watching
this video what is wrong with you
that's always stay awesome
[Music]
ah